trois volumes disait et voulait comparer
aux trois étages d'une maison alors le
premier volume c'est au rez de chaussée
alors ce sont ces la consommation oui si
vous voulez si vous voulez c'est plus
compliqué que ça oui bien sûr mais ça
peut compliquer c'est plus compliqué
parce que il faut partir de des
capitalistes pour comprendre la démarche
qui était la mienne
dans le premier volume le maux de
capitalisme n'est pas prononcé je crois
qu'on prononce une fois deux fois
sa mort a échappé ou de vous rattraper
par la suite
oui je pense a par la suite mais parce
que au rez-de-chaussée l'avancé de vie
cette vie quotidienne 7j ordinaire c'est
vide routine
le capitalisme ne joue aucun rôle alors
j'ai cherché dans le premier volume qui
s'appelle les structures du quotidien
j'ai cherché à ne pas parler du
capitalisme le premier volume où le
capitalisme n'existe pas vous parler des
gens vous parlez de oui je parle des
gens je parle des répétitions je parle d
habitude je parle à vous parler des
boissons des nourritures d'une résidence
de l'habillement mais oui mais je
parlerai je pars même des techniques je
parle des villes je parle de la monnaie
je parle de tout ce qui se répète en
quelque sorte et qui échappent je dirais
à toute initiative
le capitalisme n'est pas responsable
tandis que dans le second rallume les
jeux de les changes et bien les jeux de
les changes
c'est à la verticale j'essaie d'aller au
dessus de la vie ordinaire et j'aborde
l'économie de marché c'est d'ailleurs
les marchés les boutiques les
colporteurs les foires les bourses les
bandes les études de notaires tous ceux
qui l économie de marché et pour les
annonces et avant qui m'est resté
toujours dans la mémoire c'est la
transparence c'est-à-dire que quand vous
allez sur le marché quand vous entrez
dans une boutique vous êtes en face
d'une situation qui n'est pas une
situation tellement compliqué vous la
comprenez quitte à vous tromper vous
vous la comprenez tandis qu'au-dessus de
l'économie de marché
quand vous arrivez auprès des grands
marche auprès des banquiers auprès
d'eads est ce que j'appelle les
capitalistes faute d'avs autre mot à ce
moment là vous avez un jeu sophistiqué
si bien que l'étiquette de kapitalis
gêné plastique tout à plat tout d'abord
en haut au dessus de l'économie de
marché c'est un superlatif donc c'est le
troisième volume non non non non non non
non enregistrement c'est pas le
troisième lukas haas est second et le
troisième volume au lieu d'examiner des
choses à la verticale gd examine à
l'horizontale
une économie a toujours une région
centrale un pôle une sorte de centre
vivifiant avec des conséquences pour les
régions voisines est cette zone centrale
c'est une zone où le capitalisme existe
il existe seulement dans la zone
centrale au xviie siècle
il existe à amsterdam il existe
peut-être dans certaines régions de la
france il existe en angleterre il existe
peut-être en bout mais il n'existe pas
ailleurs ou du moins de cette façon
aussi nette à mon avis sur ces ensembles
économiques c'est ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui d'un bout qui était dérivée
de l'allemand devait retenir de charge
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'économie monde
non pas l'économie mondiale l'économie
du monde entier mais l'économie d'une
zone d'un morceau de la planète
on lira par exemple la méditerranée est
une est une économie moon
non ensuite le maire estime vais le dire
car c'est une expression à demande alors
le mot velde wirtschaft c'est ce sens un
peu double signifie à la fois en
allemand l'économie mondiale et les
quads mimose alors l'europe est une éco
demi-mot alors au coeur de l'économie
mots vous avez une sorte de chaleur
supplémentaire dans les régions voisines
c'est déjà très différents et dans les
régions marginal ou périphériques ça
n'existe plus vous avez peut-être les
moyens de production pour dire vrai
produit choix capitaliste au centre au
coeur mais vous les avez pas apte dans
les régions qui entoure cette région
centrale et vous les avez certainement
pas dans la périphérie et ce troisième
volume s'appelle le temps du monde